hi i'm kevin nelson a developer advocate
at google cloud and today i'm going to
share how google cloud bigquery can help
you unlock new value from your sap data
let's get started
so what exactly is bigquery
bigquery is google cloud's serverless
highly scalable industry-leading cloud
data warehouse it helps you easily and
cost effectively combine both sap and
other data sets to make faster better
business decisions
what sort of things are possible with
bigquery
sap enterprises around the world are
leveraging bigquery to solve business
problems that were previously
unattainable due to limitations in
traditional data warehousing
technologies
for example by consolidating data sets
and leveraging the advanced analytics
capabilities bigquery has to offer
retailers are solving for shelf outs
with predictive forecasting healthcare
companies are expediting customer
service with automated email
classification
and financial services companies are
generating more personalized banking
advice so what makes bigquery so
different
well
here are a few key features that make it
pretty special
first because it's serverless you don't
have to worry about configuring the
system performance tuning resource
provisioning reliability or even
planning for future growth
bigquery manages all that for you and
can instantly scale to handle all your
needs
this means you can spend one hundred
percent of your time on analysis and
gathering new insights to drive
innovation for your business
bigquery takes advantage of google's
full stack innovations from hardware and
storage to the network all the way to
the software that has been used to
analyze data for search for over a
decade with bigquery's unique
architecture you can run standard sql
queries on terabytes of data in seconds
and even petabytes of data within just a
few minutes
bigquery also comes with machine
learning built right in bigquery ml is
unlocking machine learning for millions
of data analysts
bigquery ml allows data analysts not
just data scientists to build and use
custom machine learning models using
simple sql statements directly within
bigquery this has been a game changer
for many organizations
bigquery also makes it easy to join your
data with other data sets
some available directly from google like
search trends and ads
and other public data sets like noaa
weather data
in fact the google cloud marketplace has
over 200 curated data sources ready to
be leveraged directly in bigquery
and there's the new integrated analytics
app providing an extended data exchange
platform
finally bigquery has proven value for
sap enterprises
global market intelligence firm idc
released a study in 2021 showing that
the average sap business reported that
their cost of data warehouse operations
was reduced by more than half while
delivering business reports 77 faster
and making analytics teams 20 percent
more productive
altogether this resulted in a three-year
return on investment of greater than 300
percent
now that we better understand the value
of bigquery just how easy is it to
integrate and get started with sap data
as an open platform bigquery can
integrate with sap using both google
cloud tooling and also partner tooling
from sap or others
let's take a look at one option that
leverages investment in a commonly used
sap replication technology slt
by using our bigquery connector for sap
you can leverage your existing
investment in sap slt to connect
directly to bigquery
your sap data is replicated in near real
time
literally within a couple of seconds
to learn more about the bigquery
connector for sap check out this earlier
video in the series linked in the
description below
but what can you do after you've
replicated data into bigquery
this is where our google cloud cortex
framework comes in
google cloud cortex is a framework to
accelerate business outcomes with less
risk complexity and cost by providing
endorsed solution content including
reference architectures deployment
accelerators and integration services
for common business scenarios
the goal is to help you accelerate
business outcomes and get up and running
quickly with google cloud
cortex data foundation provides a rich
set of building blocks and templates for
sap enterprises looking to modernize
with our data cloud including predefined
operational data marts
data processing scripts machine learning
templates and plug-and-play reporting
samples for common business use cases
all leveraging bigquery
this means that once you have replicated
data from sap into bigquery you can
implement our data foundation content
and get ready to run data models and
reports for many common business use
cases a few are highlighted here
stay tuned for more details on our
google cloud cortex framework and data
foundation for sap in a related video in
this series
okay that was a lot of information so
let's do a quick recap
by leveraging bigquery you can integrate
your sap data however you like for more
insights to scale using leading data
warehousing capabilities with proven
value for sap enterprises
by easily accessing new data sets
directly in bigquery you can help create
new insights across your organization
and give more power to your data
analytics users in a secure way
finally we help you get started quickly
by providing advanced capabilities like
bigquery machine learning built-in with
standard sql as well as out-of-the-box
data models and reporting templates for
common business scenarios
all this allows you to make better
faster business decisions
i hope you found this video useful it's
just one in a series about how google
cloud provides unique benefits for sap
customers
you can find the links to the other
videos in the series and more
information about cortex and bigquery
linked in the description below thanks
for listening
[Music]